I'm inspired by a lot of people that are go-getters,
so people that kind of make things happen inspire me.
They're everyday people,
to be totally honest with you.
Ah, I'm inspired,
one of my mentors is the owner of <em>Time Out</em> magazine.
And he inspires me because he did,
he set it up himself when he was,
ah, he got a grant from his grandmother
of like 500 pounds,
and thirty years later
he's still a well-known, global brand.
So, people like that inspire me,
people that make things happen.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.